hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
letter 87 is focused on the topic
of wealth and this can comprise a lot of
things it could be money in hand
it could be money that you think is
coming to you it could be possessions
whether the things that you're wearing
or the house that you live in
it could cover all sorts of grounds and
seneca as a stoic thinks that
wealth is not by itself a good
now when people hear that they almost
immediately switch over oh you think
wealth isn't good
you must think it's bad and seneca
doesn't think it's bad
either it's in the class of what the
stoics call
the indifference things that are in the
middle which
could be used or desired or pursued
good or in bad ways right well
or poorly but they're not by themselves
valuable and you might say wait a second
wealth isn't valuable
you can you know walk into a place and
plunk some money down and get something
with it what it what has value if not
that
well yes wealth can be exchanged for
things but it doesn't have
genuine value according to the stoics
and he begins by talking about
a stoic paradox he says i was a
shipwrecked sailor
before i ever took ship how it happened
i refrained from mentioning lest you
think it counts as one of the stoic
paradoxes
and then he says not one of them is
false not one is as strange as it seems
at first and this is the nature of
paradoxes
some genuine paradoxes are irresolvable
but the stoic paradoxes were all things
that they would assert and
other people thought well that can't be
right but then if you look at it from
the stoic perspective it actually does
make
a lot of sense and so one of the stoic
paradoxes
that he doesn't bring up but is actually
quite you know
apropos of this is only the wise person
is rich and that is paradoxical because
you can say well you can be wise and
dirt poor
look at that bum over there spouting
wisdom right he doesn't have a stitch
of extra clothing to his name and the
stuff he's wearing is rags that are
falling apart
and yet he's able to discourse like
socrates or diogenes or whoever
well rich you know is going to be
something that we're going to measure
in other ways and it takes a little
while to shift our perspective
to do that seneca thinks that most
people have mixed up ideas about wealth
so he tells us a little story
about the recent trip that he took and
he says
the trip has taught me how many of our
possessions are superfluous
we can do without them how easily we can
allay them aside by choice
since when necessity deprives us of them
we do not feel the loss now
a lot of people do feel the loss you
know they drop their phone
into the i don't know
into the aqueduct and it gets wetter so
oh my gosh i've lost
everything seneca would say no you've
lost the stuff that was on your phone
and you may incur some inconveniences
tracking the information down
and it's going to cost you a little bit
of money to get a new phone if you want
a new phone
but you haven't lost yourself and so
he goes on and he gives examples about
you know eating figs
and you know riding in a country wagon
and all that sort of stuff
the most interesting part of this is
where he talks about
debt he says when it's a matter of
income you size up a man carefully
before you entrust him with a loan
or even with a benefit for you regard
benefits to his expenditures
this is the way that people who are
obsessed with money look at things
doing a good deed for something they
they want to know the cash value
he says his property is extensive but so
too are his debts he has a lovely house
but he borrowed money to purchase it no
one turns out a more splendid retinue
but he doesn't pay his bills
and he says do you think a person is
rich just because they have
nice things because they eat from golden
plates they own a plantation in every
province
their account fills a fat scroll he says
this person is a poor man all the same
why because he's in debt and then
somebody could say
well wait a second what about a rich guy
who's not actually in debt who actually
has all of this stuff
and isn't you know sort of pretending or
coasting along
on creditors he says
well he's in debt too how
much does he owe you ask everything
and seneca here says something really
important
or do you perhaps think that owing one's
goods to fortune is somehow different
from owing a human creditor
what is he saying there every nice thing
that you've got
can be taken away this you know
i'll use myself as an example this nice
chalkboard
somebody could come along and break it
this wonderful
seneca book somebody can come along and
burn it
i could drop it off of a high building
and never see it again
this tie that i you know enjoy wearing
and
and it was quite attractive they could
get ripped apart
and we could go on and on and on even
your body you know you're going to give
it back sooner or later and it's not
going to stay the same by the way as it
gets older
and more out of shape even if you do
exercise
sooner or later you're going to give it
back to fortune so
this is an important way to sort of
reconfigure
our views on property possessions
and wealth seneca is now for the rest of
the letter
going to put forth a bunch of
syllogistic
arguments for why wealth is not
a good and then he's going to provide us
with some important
explanations and i'm not putting every
single argument on the board because
we've got them in the text and we can
run through them instead we want to look
at
what the argument is and what he has to
say about the argument by way of
explanation
so the first argument that he makes the
first syllogism
goes like this that which is good
makes people good just as in musical
skill
that which is good makes one a musician
that's the first premise things
depending on fortune do not make a
person good
and then the conclusion is thus such
things are not goods and he says
against this the peripatetics or the
aristotelians argue our first premise is
false people do not automatically become
good from what is good
in music there are things that are good
for example a flute a liar or an organ
an instrument
for playing but none of these makes a
person a musician and this is quite true
all you need to do is go into a guitar
store
and see some rich kid you know buying a
guitar
and picking it out and plunking away on
it and you're like well that guy
sucks he's not a musician at all he's
not good
buying the super expensive guitar
doesn't actually make him good
now seneca says here's our reply you
don't understand our premise about
what's good in music
we're not referring to the equipment
we're referring to the things that make
a person
a musician you're only considering the
accoutrements of the skill
you don't look to the skill itself what
is the good thing in music
it's the musicianship it's the skill
it's the talent it's it's the
exercise and experience that eventually
becomes consolidated in an ability to
play well
so what's good is making
somebody good but gifts of fortune are
not
doing that so he says i want to make the
point a little bit more clear
good in the skill of music is set in two
different ways one referring to what
promotes the musician's results
the other to what promotes his skill the
instrument flutes and organs and strings
have to do with the results not with the
skill
itself so because the musician is
skilled even without them although
although he might not be able to use his
skill
where the human being is concerned
though we don't find the same duality
for the good of a human being
is the good of a life
wealth is not the sort of thing
that can actually provide you with that
good
i mean you can say well can't you buy a
book of stoic philosophy sure
but the buying of it doesn't
automatically make you learn it
right it just puts the the tool in your
hands
and now it's up to you to actually read
it
and make it part of your life and like
seneca says you know it takes a lot of
time to cultivate that
let's look at the second premise the
second syllogism
he says that which can belong to the
vilest and most despicable kinds of
people is not a good
but wealth can belong to the pimp and
the manager of gladiators
therefore wealth is not a good now you
might say
what's wrong with being a manager of
gladiators i mean that sounds like a
pretty cool job doesn't it
and here's where you know so many people
get misled
by the little bits of ancient culture
that they get to see through the media
being a gladiator was being a slave
and being the kind of person who made
their money by managing slaves
was actually viewed as being
disreputable
being kind of disgusting sometimes
people like that would get you know
glorified but they'd get glorified in
the same way that
sometimes you know we look at things
that we know are supposed to be gross
and we're like yeah that that's really
cool i'm going to be edgy and push it
right
so this is worth thinking about
can something that's actually you know
the
belongs to and is sought after by those
who we look at as being
morally depraved on the wrong track
can that really be a genuine good
and so you know here's where seneca
considers a counter example he says
your premise is false which premise
in the teaching of literature medicine
and navigation we see that the relevant
goods belong to the humblest kinds of
people
now you know teaching of literature you
might say well wait a second what do you
mean a humblest kind of person
well a lot of times the people who were
the tudors
were slaves in ancient rome very often
brought from greece
or medicine doctors were not highly
regarded
i mean they weren't totally at the
bottom of society but they
they didn't have the status that we gave
them now or navigation
you know teaching people how to do this
he says these these skills don't make
any claim to greatness of spirit they
don't sort of the heights
they don't despise the things of fortune
virtue is different
virtue elevates a person and places him
above
all that mortals hold dear and you know
he gives some example about
people who would do you know
things that that are considered to be
disgusting
and he says that there are those whom
wealth befalls in the same way as silver
coins
fall in the sewer virtue takes its stand
above such things it's assessed in its
own
currency things that can belong to just
anybody don't
count with it as goods medicine and
navigation don't debar themselves and
their practitioner from the admiration
of such things
someone who's not a good man can still
be a doctor a helmsman a teaching
teacher of literature and he says for
heaven's sake even a cook
right but you can't be a good person
without having virtue so if we think
about the things that can be
shared if the stoics are right then that
means that if people that we
we look down on or say well they're not
they're not good people
can enjoy that thing it's not truly a
good
even though we might enjoy it too it's
just not
a good in the true sense
there's a really interesting argument
that he provides
after that and here he starts talking
about causes
he says that which is good does not come
of what is bad but wealth comes of
avarice therefore wealth is not a good
so for those who don't know what is
avarice another word for it is greed
wealth comes from this desire to have
wealth
right you desire wealth therefore you
you work to get it or you scheme or you
do whatever you're going to do
invent the proverbial better mouse trap
right
and then you get the money and
so seneca is saying here
that wealth is coming from something
that is bad so wealth cannot be
something good
he says one might say it's not true that
good does not arise from what is bad
because money arises from temple robbery
and theft and he says thus temple
robbing and theft are indeed bad but
only because they produce more bad
consequences than good
for they yield of profit but they also
produce fear anxiety torments
of mind and body and then he says this
is a terrible argument
terrible counter-argument whoever says
this must admit that just as temple
robbery is bad
insofar as it produces bad consequences
it's also good because it produces a
good consequence for you and we don't
want to say
that sort of thing by the way temple
robbery why is this a big deal
oh because it's pissing off the gods no
no it has nothing to do with that
temples were where people
left money it was like a bank so this is
sort of like
robbing the bank being a bank robber is
not a
good thing um
so he goes on and he says goods cannot
arise
from what is actually bad and then he he
has another thing that he says it's
quite interesting
the greatest penalty for criminal acts
is in the acts themselves
now that is paradoxical is it not to say
that those who do the wrong thing
the biggest punishment is that they
actually do the wrong thing because
why is that a punishment they want to do
the wrong thing don't they they're
getting to do what they like and they're
getting away with it in many cases
he says you're mistaken if you make them
wait for the prisoner or the executioner
such acts are punished right away when
performed indeed in the very act of
performing them
therefore good does not arise from what
is bad any more than a fig
from an olive tree goods cannot but
run true to type he says
now he says that some other members of
his school
answer this objection as follows
so here's entertaining the possibility
that money could be good
suppose that money is a good regardless
of where it's obtained
even so and even if money is sometimes
gained by temple robbing it's not the
case that the money actually came from
one's robbing the temple
think about it like this a gold coin is
in the same jar with a snake
if you take out the the coin you did not
take it out by reason of the snake being
there as well
that is to say the jar does not supply
me with gold because it also contains a
snake
it supplies gold in spite of the fact
that it contains a snake in the same way
temple robbing produces a profit not
because it's a despicable and criminal
act
but because it contains profit as well
so you can have the the good
and the bad is just kind of accidental
to it and then he says
these two cases are not the same at all
in the one i can take out the gold
without the stake and the other i cannot
have the prophet without
robbing the temple the prophet is not
adjacent to the crime
but combined with it so when we desire
wealth for you know the wrong reasons
you know there's no getting around
that aspect of it he also talks about
results and he's got an argument here
about results he says
if the pursuit of something brings many
bad results that thing is not a good
our pursuit of wealth brings many bad
results therefore
wealth is not a good and he says
okay somebody might question this one
your premise has two meanings one
meaning is that our pursuit of wealth
brings many bad results
but let's take a counter example
our pursuit of virtue also brings many
bad results
a person takes ship for reasons of study
and is shipwrecked
or captured right they wanted to be
virtuous but it brought about some
bad results then he says the second
meaning is like this
that through which we get bad results is
not a good he says
from a pr such a premise we can't infer
that we get bad results through wealth
or through pleasure or else if we get
many bad results through wealth and
wealth is not only a good but actually a
bad thing
but your school says only that wealth is
not a good not that it's a bad
thing besides you grant that wealth has
its uses
you count it as one of the advantages of
life and so he says well here's a
response to that
you're wrong to think that wealth is a
disadvantage wealth does not harm anyone
what does the harm is one's own
foolishness
or the iniquity of another just as a
sword doesn't harm anyone but only the
tool
is only the tool of the slayer so wealth
doesn't hurt you because you're harmed
for the sake of your wealth and he says
here's a better response and this comes
from the stoic philosopher posidonius
he says wealth is a cause of evils
not because wealth itself does anything
bad itself
right the dollar bills don't do anything
or the stock certificates but it
motivates those who will
do bad things and he talks about here a
difference between
what he calls an efficient cause and an
antecedent cause and here we're getting
into a little bit of stoic metaphysics
that we don't have to go too deep into
suffice it to say an efficient cause is
something that
makes something happen an antecedent
cause
is something that's there in the chain
of causality but it doesn't directly
make the thing happen rather it sets
things up in such a way
that something can happen so he says
here
good things or wealth has this latter
sort of causality it inflames the mind
gives birth to arrogance attracts
resentment and sets the mind at odds
with itself
to such an extent we delight to have a
reputation for affluence even though
their reputation is likely to hurt us
so the wealth by itself doesn't do
anything
but it brings out the worst stuff in us
attributable to us by the way not
actually attributable to the wealth
and he says listen good things are pure
they they don't corrupt the mind they
don't cause anxiety
they elevate and expand the mind right
and he says somebody might go too far
and say wealth is not only a good
not only not a good thing but is even a
bad thing and
seneca says no no because it doesn't
harm us in itself
it doesn't have efficient causality but
we do have to be
careful with wealth because of that and
then it goes on and talks about
some other arguments that posidonius is
giving and there's actually two
syllogisms here
posidonia says that you should reason
like this those things which confer on
the mind neither greatness nor
confidence nor freedom from anxiety
are not goods that's one premise wealth
health and similar things do not do any
of these things
second premise therefore they're not
goods and then he expands the
syllogism saying those things which
confer on the mind neither greatness nor
confidence nor freedom from anxiety but
instead produce
extravagance conceit and arrogance are
bad
things dependent on fortune drive us to
these ladder therefore they are not
goods
now notice he's not saying that that by
this wealth would become something bad
but it's definitely not a good and the
idea here
is that you know we the the greatest
values are these things
uh greatness of mind confidence freedom
from anxiety
if you can't actually provide that then
it's not really a good
and he seneca goes on and says one might
say by this reasoning there
will not even be advantages or what the
stoics would call
preferred indifference and he says
advantages are of a different status
from goods an advantage is that in which
there's more utility
than an annoyance a good has to be a
genuine good
and innocent of any sort of harm so a
good is on a higher level
than something that is merely
advantageous something that's
useful something that is convenient
the last syllogism that seneca
is going to provide here
runs like this and and this is a little
tricky one
it says that which is good is not made
up of things that are bad
but many instances of poverty make up
one instance of wealth
therefore wealth is not a good let's
contextualize this a little bit so
something that's good is not going to be
made up of a whole bunch of instances of
something that's bad
what would be being poor okay so if i
only have ten dollars in my pocket
i'm pretty poor at least here in the
united states right
if that's all i have to subsist on i'm
you know
i got maybe one or two meals ahead of me
and that's about it
depending on where i'm living now
what if i multiply that by a thousand
and i've got ten thousand dollars that's
actually a lot of money
it's not that much money it's not like i
could live on that for a year
unless i'm being extremely frugal so
let's uh add another
thousand of that and now we've got 10
million oh now i'm really rich right
that 10 million is made up of a whole
bunch of little ten
dollars and each of those ten dollars is
a little bit of poverty
so how do you combine all this poverty
and make wealth well you do so by
engaging in
sophistical reasoning right and seneca
says this is not a good argument
this is this syllogism is not recognized
by our school
it's both devised and solved by the
peripatetics the aristotelians
posidonius however says this sophism
which has been bandied about by
dialecticians is refuted by
auntie potter who is one of the stoic
skull arcs
by saying this and here's a good
argument
poverty refers not to possession but to
subtraction or as the ancients call the
privation
it refers not to what someone has but
what they don't have
thus it's not possible for anything to
be filled up from many
instances of emptiness wealth is made up
of numerous resources not numerous
instances of scarcity you don't properly
understand what poverty is poverty is
not the condition of possessing a few
things
but that of not possessing many things
being deprived of many things
its meaning is not derived from what it
has but what it lacks
and so you know this is a very
interesting metaphysical resolution
and you notice seneca is willing to
reject that argument and and that says
something
seneca only wants to use arguments that
he thinks are actually on point with
this
and he's going to be very critical about
how these arguments are used
here's the question we want to close
with that seneca is is kind of closing
with him
himself how effective are these
syllogisms do they actually
convince people do they change their
mind do they help them see
that wealth itself is not the good that
so many people and our culture and the
culture of seneca's time
present it as being that we need to
instead
shift our focus to something that's
genuinely good
like virtue
you